et jeudi devant la france entière tu m'a
mis un coup de couteau dans le dos sans
le savoir je sais que vous l'aimez je
sais qu'ici tous les chroniqueurs se
faisait une joie de recevoir
franck dubosc parce que vous trouvez
qu'il a un immense talent vous l'aimez
sur scène vous l'aimez au cinéma et moi
en plus c'était vraiment un ami quand
j'ai un ami c'est vraiment un homme nous
parler alain par jusqu'à cet après midi
mais voilà rien
cet après midi franck quand même et je
le dis devant la france entière
tu m'a mis un coup de couteau dans le
dos sans le savoir h 30
je sais que tu prépares ton prochain
long métrage rumba la vie
il n'est pas mis en écoute et franck
c'est toi qui a écrit ce film c'est toi
qui va réaliser ce film
malheureusement franck je suis tombé
sur cette petite annonce aujourd'hui un
homme 35 50 ans sachant bien jouer au
ping pong pour film franck dubosc
réalisé par et avec franck dubosc
il cherche quelqu'un sachant très bien
jouer au bingo pour ton film là et tu
vas vous dire qu à aucun instant tu n'a
pensé à moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais partent en vacances correspond à 35
alors il cherche quelqu'un en plus y'a
pas alors je vous le dis je vous dis
dans le cinéma ya ya normalement hier
figuration ça veut dire on te voit
silhouette c'est mieux ne plus passer
mais non silhouette c'est mieux
silhouette c'est mieux là en
l'occurrence c'est mieux s'il ya une
partie de ping pong mais il n'est pas
obligé de jouer bien raison lancés ça
j'ai dit non il peut jouer mal ça peut
être drôle aussi
et tu penses plus sûr - mc decaux et
quand je dis ça j'ai voyez plutôt vers
cyril hanouna
j'espère que voilà donc qui coûte si tu
veut pas de moi photo getty c'est que tu
le fais pas tu te fait réfléchir là tout
à coup en quoi c'est une bonne idée
finalement tout à rentrer tôt lundi
enfin on peut dire et tout de suite
moi ça ne te demande rien je reverserai
le cacher au public viendra nous sait
combien ces 150 euros pour une
silhouette qui parle le cacher c'est sur
50 ou non mais ce que tu obligé comme
les assurances
ouais les assurances algérie je leur
verse se cacher mais est-ce que je peux
être dans ce [ __ ] de film de série de
même la drève regard la dre voir adresse
à la bresse adresse moi même l'adresse à
paris région parisienne et saint coran
car si foot macquarie s'est complètement
toi oui c'est pour toi c'est vrai que je
le pensais j'ai presque penser à jouer
si vous voulez quoi peut-être capable je
suis capable de tout faire je vous dis
bien tous fois qu on va faire un petit
truc je vais faire le top 5 de tes films
ce que j'ai fait un petit top 5 de tes
films avec des extraits parce que pour
les gens de les réclamer et à la fin de
ce top 5
tu vas prendre ta décision car il dira
si oui on leur pression et je ferai part
qui se plus tard le film
question si d'aventuré frank était
téméraire et disait mais non cyril nom
se tasse alors ouais je vous dis ça
restera un ami oui voilà je vous le dis
parce que au moins il aura eu la
franchise de me le dire droit dans les
aimait pas faire ça derrière moi c'est
parfait mais c'est distribue déjà donc
faire le rôle de ma fille ça c'est pas
fin au rôle de faire le rôle de ma fille
mais fait que tu te rases ça alors je
peux pas non ça fait quand le tournage
est écrite en mai juin juillet mais je
suis libre
bizarrement ça peut toutefois quelques
pas un petit moment pour réfléchir
[Musique]